to deliver the best personalized
customer experiences businesses must
understand how their consumers think
and behave
so how can companies use consumer data
and ai to predict demand and scale
services in real time while still
preserving privacy let's find out in
this edition of the ai training ground
during the summer in denmark nearly 75
000 concert goers double the size of a
nearby town during a week-long festival
every logistical challenge from
transportation traffic management food
and beverage provisions sanitation sales
and supply chain
needs to be addressed on site in real
time so how can ai be used to shape a
better experience to start festival
attendees all wear smart wristbands
during the event these are used for
cashless payments for almost a million
transactions
the data collected provides insights
from ticketing information purchasing
patterns and location data it's the fuel
that keeps the festival at peak
performance and gives a real-time view
of consumer behavior but with so much
data being collected there are
challenges the data needs to be
accessible to even be harnessed and if
it's all living in silos and can't be
combined with other data sets it can't
be used to make accurate predictions on
the day of the festival by combining
multiple years with external data
sources such as weather you can predict
attendance and supply chain demands for
future events
in 2018 nearly 40 percent of the food
items were returned costing festival
planners both time and money
but with predictive ai this could have
been avoided there's also the issue of
preserving privacy with all the customer
data being collected festivalgoers want
to be sure their private data remains
just that
private and that it's not being misused
or leaked by anonymizing this customer
data and scrubbing all digital traces of
personal information
businesses can use sensitive data to
innovate securely
and responsibly
designing and implementing trustworthy
ai requires a deep understanding of the
human problem you're trying to solve for
with a human-centric approach you can
create better outcomes for your
customers
and for your business
learn more about building predictive ai
that's secure with ibm's ai training
ground
[Music]
you